Why do people keep making movies about a guy
who shoots webs out of his wrists?
Because they're fun, and that's not just true
for the audience.
The people making them seem to be having a
blast, too.
Here are some times when things got a little
silly on set.
In Spider-Man: Homecoming, Tom Holland's Peter
Parker has a full and busy life.
In addition to superheroics, he's got to juggle
homework with a spot on his school's academic
team, not to mention working as an intern
at Stark Industries.
In one scene, he tries to talk his way out
of an upcoming academic decathlon, and his
advisor won't take no for an answer.
Peter sputters off a list of his responsibilities,
and it turns out that "responsibilities" is
something of a trigger word.
It's the crux of a Spider-Man mantra, after
all.
When he flubs the line, he can't help but
break character, give a wry turn to the camera,
and recite the phrase predecessor Tobey Maguire
made mainstream:
"Mr. Stark and my internship, you know, I...I've
got a lot of responsibility with it.
With great power comes great responsibility."
When Spider-Man 2 opens, Peter Parker has
already endured a lot as Spider-Man.
He's in college at that point, but still the
same clumsy guy in public, picking up none
of the gracefulness of his superhero side.
In one scene, Peter drops all of his books
and school supplies while walking on campus.
That was supposed to happen.
What came as a surprise to Tobey Maguire was
what happened next.
As he stays in character, grumbling and picking
up his things as other students walk by, one
faceless extra slams their backpack into Maguire's
head and catches a strap on his neck.
This blooper is actually a prank, courtesy
of director Sam Raimi.
He's the guy with the backpack, surprising
Maguire and making him laugh.
While Spider-Man isn't as loaded as Batman
or powerful as Superman, he does have one
big thing in common with them: He's an orphan.
Those other guys were raised by a butler and
some kindly farmers, while Spider-Man grew
into a goofy and friendly teen thanks to his
Aunt May and Uncle Ben.
In a rapid-fire barrage of bloopers from the
set of Spider-Man: Homecoming, Ned, played
by Jacob Batalon, and Peter try to talk to
Liz about the current teen party scene, and
Peter mentions how parents sometimes let their
kids throw those parties.
That bit of dialogue sends Holland off the
rails.
He remembers that his character doesn't exactly
have biological parents anymore.
"They let you have parties, you know?
My parents are…dead."
A quiet, heartfelt moment with the object
of your affection can make even the most confident
person into a tongue-tied mess.
But hey, sometimes deep thoughts and feelings
are better left unsaid, right?
That would make one Spider-Man 2 blooper extremely
realistic, except Tobey Maguire isn't supposed
to be so wordlessly flummoxed in a cute, romantic
scene with Kirsten Dunst, who's playing Mary
Jane Watson.
"I…"
To his credit, he sells that mistake as simply
being overwhelmed by emotion.
But then he realizes he's been silent for
way too long, and that the jig is up.
Part of what makes Spider-Man such a great
character are the differences between the
bold superhero and his mild-mannered alter-ego.
Spider-Man is Peter Parker, of course, but
they're also total opposites, at least to
the casual observer.
For example, Spider-Man glides through the
air with the greatest of ease.
Peter Parker, on the other hand, is a gangly
and timid teen who's not quite comfortable
in his own skin.
In Spider-Man: Homecoming, the actor meant
to embody both Peter and Spider-Man really
nailed Peter Parker's awkwardness.
Tom Holland is almost too deep in character;
the actor apparently tripped, slipped, and
stumbled quite a lot during the making of
the movie.
Maybe Tobey Maguire feels uncomfortable doing
romantic scenes in action-heavy superhero
movies.
Or maybe he doesn't think the idea of introducing
the comics character Gwen Stacy is necessary
for the already overstuffed Spider-Man 3,
which already has so many characters.
Or maybe the actor has just gone a little
stir-crazy from playing Spider-Man in three
movies over five years.
Whatever the reason, Maguire can't seem to
get through filming close-up coverage on what's
supposed to be a simple exchange in which
Gwen introduces herself to the Daily Bugle
photographer.
"We got it under control."
"And action."
"Hi, Peter!"
"Hi!"
Was it the blonde wig?
Spider-Man's web swinging is a special effect
achieved with some combination of green-screen,
CGI, and actors suspended from gravity-defying
wires.
Being harnessed up like that is not exactly
a natural, or comfortable state.
It takes a lot of effort to get used to, let
alone do a good job of acting in that condition.
On the set of Spider-Man: Homecoming, Tom
Holland couldn't seem to get the hang of those
dangling wires.
He tries to turn his inability to navigate
the wires into a little dance in front of
his concerned co-star Donald Glover.
"Whoa!
Hey, are you all right, man?"
"I got it!"
In more wire-based shenanigans, while shooting
a night scene for Spider-Man 3, Tobey Maguire
guides Kirsten Dunst down to the safety of
the ground, while notably not wearing his
Spidey suit.
Dunst has so much fun with the descent that
she lets out a couple of hoots, which seemingly
causes Maguire to forget his line.
He improvises some silliness instead:
"Whoo!"
"Let's go get on my bike!"
"Okay!"
In Avengers: Infinity War, when Thanos snaps
half the universe to death, Spider-Man falls
into the arms of his mentor Tony Stark before
turning to dust.
"I don't wanna go.
I don't wanna go, sir.
Please.
I don't wanna go.
I don't wanna go."
It's heartbreaking, which means Holland probably
wanted to keep things light and bouncy when
his character miraculously returns in Avengers:
Endgame.
In fact, the actor literally bounces around
the rubble-strewn set, much to the pleasure
of Downey Jr., who hugs the boy wonder for
just a little too long, and even plants a
kiss on his cheek.
Welcome back, Wall Crawler.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about superhero
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.